I'm wondering how much are you guys  looking forward to reuniting for Suicide  Squad movie and how are you characters  and chemistry differ in that film  compared to focus I don't know what it's  going to be characterized yeah but I  don't know what is what the  relationships really gonna be it's  ever-changing yeah yeah but it's really  cool they the waited David Ayer works  it's all images all ideas and he holds  the screenplay holds the screenplay and  he just keeps sending you things about  your character you just want you to be  prepared for for anything so I think  we're gonna be allies for sure yeah yeah  we're definitely allies I really I  really we're not being secretive we just  actually don't yeah we actually yeah he  only sends you your characters stuff so  you don't know what's going on with the  other characters and things I think he  wants it to come alive on set when you  start that middle of April yeah  you